- Yo, hanging out in the lobby.
Can’t wait to see what celebrity rappers will be joining the game.
Ugh, it’s just football players.
- [Computer voice:] It's time to expose frauds based on limited info
and pure mob mentality.
You must vote out the impost—
- [Together:] Bears.
- The only way to prove we're not frauds is by doing silly little tasks.
- We have to use our legs? No fair.
- Ugh, why is it so hard to connect?
- Ayo, I can’t get these cards to work.
- No problem! We love to share targets now.
- Gruden’s trying to sabotage!
- I ain’t no fraud, man. I'm just trying to figure out these dang masks, man.
- Fraud’s not us. We’ve won four games!
- Against the NFC East!
- [Gasping]
- Bucs are sus.
- Yeah, I’m sus: successful under stress.
- Well, we’re undefeated.
- Only because of the Titans'...situation.
- Vote brown, man. Every year the Browns are frauds, man.
- NO! NO, I’M TRYING AGAIN.
- [Computer voice:] The Browns were somehow not frauds.
- Oh wow.
- Good for them.
- That's what's up, Browns.
- [Computer voice:] Several frauds remain.
- YOU DIDN'T BEAT THE CHIEFS. YOU DIDN'T BEAT THE CHIEFS. I BEAT THE CHIEFS!
- It's fine, I'm pretty sure it's still fourth down.
- Oh hell yeah, man. Violence and death? Now this is a game.
- [Humming]
Never give up kids.
One day you too could be an internet-famous, third-string QB.
And that's the Trace McSorley guarantee.